[Music]
whilst how to train your dragon' the
hidden world is the third film in the
franchise in many ways it feels like a
first outing with many aspects of the
series being revitalized in interesting
and enjoyable ways there's a lot to
unpack for fans of the franchise and
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the movie and its ending there
will be heavy spoilers here in regards
to the film so if you don't want to know
anything about How to Train Your Dragon
3 and I highly suggest that you turn off
now don't forget to stick around until
the end to hear my thoughts on the movie
as well as Whiteoak from the film
without the way I'm definition and
welcome to the channel where I watch it
so you don't have to the film opens with
hiccup and toothless infiltrating a
dragon trapper ship to rescue the
captured dragons in order to set them
free and allow them to come and live on
birth hiccup has been filling in the
role of chief since his father's death
but he really battles with the feeling
that he may not be fulfilling his
father's footsteps in addition to this
Berk has become massively overcrowded
due to the sheer amount of dragons that
now populate it and in the film The
Villages set out to find a new home
where the two species can coexist
peacefully from here we are introduced
to the villain of the piece who is a
notoriously evil dragon slayer called
grimille the grisly criminal believes
that he has slayed every last one of the
night Furies and he thinks that humans
and Dragons shouldn't coexist as the
former is superior to the latter when
he's informed by warlords about
toothless he sets out when I've been
dead a throughout the film that
eventually leads to him and hiccup going
head to head early on grimille uses a
white Night Fury or a light fury as it
eventually comes to be called to lure
toofus to him the dragons fall in love
and the light fury helps to first tap
into its hidden potential as well as
leading him to a world of hidden dragons
unfortunately grimille finds the
villagers and captures toothless light
fury and the other dragons criminal
brings the dragons to the Warlord's but
tells them that he plans to
Koufos for himself luckily the heroes
dive in to the rescue have managed to
steer the dragon trapper ships into each
other causing now to sink hiccup and
grimille take to the skies with the
former attempting to free the light fury
and with her and toothless as health
hiccup is able to send grimille to a
watery grave with the Birkins winning
the day they go to celebrate their
victory but it's at this point that
hiccup realizes that it's time to let
toothless go
this is the real conclusion of the
trilogy with the two realizing that
though they love each other it's time to
allow one another to go and be with
their own people this is because
humanity isn't mature enough to coexist
with dragons and by remaining in each
others worlds there will only be danger
even though the two characters are
friends and want to live with each other
they bid farewell and go off on their
own it's a real tear-jerking moment that
feels like the best way to send the two
off from one another but the revelations
don't in there hiccup and Astrid get
married and after a couple of years they
have summoned daughter and ride out on a
boat the hidden world to discover that
mirroring this the light fury and
toothless have gone on to have their own
children there's lots of callbacks to
the original film in their meeting and
it really feels like an outstanding way
to close off the trilogy hiccup vows to
keep the secret of the dragons safe and
to allow humanity to think that they are
gone for good with only the berkians
knowing that they still exist he hopes
that one day that they may be able to
return to when the two species could
live together in peace and this brings
the film and trilogy to a close and now
on to my review How to Train Your Dragon
the hidden world is very much a metaphor
for learning to let go and what makes it
so perfect for audiences is that
children will be able to put themselves
in the shoes of toothless whilst parents
will be in the position to pick up both
characters have to give something up so
that the other can move on and continue
forward and the piece is very much about
accepting that sometimes we have to give
something up that we love that someone
else to be happy the hidden world itself
is a utopia and hiccup would forever be
holding toothless back from this
paradise if he chose to hold on to him
forever similar to this fans must learn
to let go of this franchise too as it
will likely be the last in the series
even though I'm sure people are
desperate for a sequel this film has a
real heart to it and I'm sure many can
relate to being in a position where
they've had to let something go that
they love this is what elevates it above
most animations and it definitely feels
like one of the best movies of the year
so far and whilst it hasn't had much
competition that doesn't mean that the
position is undeserved
How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world is a masterpiece of
family-friendly storytelling with many
morals and metaphors that can easily
apply to modern life it continues and
concludes is excellent trilogy and is
enjoyable from start to finish because
of this obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the movie and what you took
from it make sure you leave your review
in the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my breakdown of the
top three theories on Captain Marvel
which will be linked at the end this is
the channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
they like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]